good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday i hope
everyone had an amazing
delightful super bowl weekend i know i
did i know i did wow what a weekend so
much is going on this morning that we
have
to unpack yeah we're a little late sorry
to those who were waiting for the
episode but it's been a crazy morning
it's been a crazy morning was a crazy
weekend we were both away on our
respective little road trips
and then there was a huge storm
yesterday i was planning to drive back
yesterday with my friends but
none of us wanted to drive in the snow
and the snow was like literally it was
crazy
you couldn't leave early and you
couldn't leave late and you couldn't
leave in the middle we were truly stuck
so we just made the best of it i
actually wound up having an amazing
super bowl sunday with my friends
and then we woke up at 6am this morning
and drove straight to the studio did my
makeup here
which is why like i'm wearing a pair of
shoes that i would probably never wear
on the show
but i didn't go home first and it was
the weather like blame it
on the weatherman you know i
two drove straight but i stopped at home
so that's why i look like much better
than you
wow hurtful i just feel like my sweater
is just it's really
it's actually a cute sweater but one
that i never planned to wear on the show
is more of like a lounge sweater because
i don't know that it's super flattering
but i did the best that i could and i
actually wound up really maximizing my
weekend
and it was it was fabulous you know like
whenever i have like a sleepover let's
say on a weekend
i'm the type of gal who wakes up on
sunday morning and just runs home
because i'd like to
you know make my sundays productive
clean my house wash my hair
and so i miss out on like a big chunk of
sleepover while i'm running home on
sunday mornings and it was something
crazy about like spending
usually at brian's like i'll wake up and
just bounce but spending the whole day
there we went snow tubing we got super
bowl we made chili we made queso we made
a roast chicken
like it was so fabulous so fabulous
so it all worked out maybe the
weatherman you know had a little
something up his sleeve he just
knew we needed like a little bit more
weekend yeah
for being at home were to make my
spinach artichoke dip well magnolia
table recipe
hang with bruce and watch the super bowl
and i wound up doing all those things
just with my friends
and without bruce and without bruce
which was really hard yeah and i still
haven't seen bruce and
i could he's on the loose well me and
theo like spent the weekend like falling
in love all over i heard i heard
it was headline news it was such a good
weekend and mark i
made margo come with me and she brought
magnolia and tpg has like a beautiful
home with tons of rooms but
of course like i made margo sleep with
me and it was in the bed me margot theo
magnolia and it was like
heaven heaven even though i slept
horribly like the
magnolia lays on your head and theo lays
on your feet like you just you're
getting it
i've heard that magnolia lays on your
head i'm sleeping and i hear something
like sniffing and scratching behind me
i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm not used to that theo above my
bed so it was just a lot and i didn't
necessarily like have a good sleep
but i enjoyed myself with my family yeah
you definitely had like a fulfilling
meaningful sleep
and that's more important arguably yeah
it's a new sensation that really sounds
like so heavenly
um i'm jealous and i'm sad for bruce
that like experience that but sometimes
you know the cousins have to hang out
without the youngest cousin
that's okay not old enough to ride this
ride but it was nice like i
i feel like i usually do like the most
for the super bowl but it was just like
very
you know relaxed and it was nice i drank
wine it was just lovely
it was really lovely it and i just like
watched it there was no one there that
was like so invested like stressing me
out like
yeah like i was like registering what
was happening but like no no emotions
were invested except i remember that i
had fifty dollars coming to me
my palms are itchy i've got money coming
in hey claude where's my venmo
okay you know what i'll send it even
though like i thought it was really more
of a
like hypothetically well i mean that but
i'll send it you sent the request let me
make watching the game more interesting
so if we're not going to follow through
it's like what are we doing well the
thing is
is that i'm so glad you brought that up
because i was in pennsylvania
where it is legal to bet on sports so
you can download
apps like draftkings sportsbook that
will only work when you're in certain
states
so during for i bet like money on random
things like the coin toss
who was going to win and even though i
did think the chiefs would um
i would i was hoping it was their time i
did bet on the buccaneers because i'm
not stupid
and i made 400 dollars so i'll give you
my 50. wow that's so great because last
night you caught me you're like i lost
well such money i can't pay the thing is
is that the 400
that i made you can also play blackjack
on this app and i
i lost it all i didn't end up cashing
out my winnings because i lost it all on
so i was like i was net even but it felt
like i lost but did you have a good time
i did i like i could never live in a
state where it's
legal because these apps make it too
easy and you know when you're playing at
blackjack on an app like it's so rigged
against you because it's so for
sure she can literally be i sent it
you're welcome wow thanks so much i just
love being you know
true to our word you know egg you're
right i'm a woman of my words
and one time it will be your time yeah
it's just it was like
so not the chief's time like not even no
not even not even one touchdown like
disgraceful but they got like some
points on the board yeah but not from a
touchdown like from the kicks
it was really disgraceful and you know
what not that i'm an analyst or anything
but the true disgrace was the defense on
the chiefs like
it wasn't patrick mahomes fault they
kept sacking him yeah so it's like where
is the line of defense no they were not
protecting him whatsoever that's their
job
to protect at all costs and there was
not even one not a cost not a single
cause
that was frustrating even though like i
knew they were going to lose but i just
love an underdog story i know i just
thought it was going to be
um like more interesting and
more of a nail-biter i feel like for the
last few super bowls it's like really
just been like there's a winner the
whole time and i find that so boring
like
give us a game yeah but at least like
there was points being scored i think
the most boring super bowls is where
there's like no touchdowns like
nothing's really happening
yeah also i felt like you know the super
bowl came at a great time for our
country i felt very unified watching the
super bowl like
just everyone was online like talking
about the same thing and like it was
just
even though it's like you know different
teams like we're all in it together no
there was a lot of excitement
and it was it was nice to just see like
a big sporting event like old times
yeah just like old times and there were
people in the stadiums like it was crazy
yeah but they weren't really showing us
a lot of the stadium even when they did
the field stuff at the end like
it was like on portrait mode everything
in the background was blurred okay the
whole super bowl was on portrait mode
and is that like an artistic style or
they just don't want people like be
seeing what's going on in the background
and like someone at cbs got a new camera
and they couldn't stop playing with the
portrait mode feature i was so confused
they did it once i'm like oh that's cool
but time and time again it's like all
right we get it you have the new feature
no and also when i was watching the end
it was like tom in portrait mode and
then the back of travis kelsey like
going into
back into the locker room and i felt
like i was watching a movie no it was
about
the end of the movie i mean ask me how
many times i've watched a video of
giselle and the kids running down to hug
tom brady
so cute so cute and i just really felt
like i did a little bit of research
because i feel like a lot of people
are always like interested in you know
the bridget moynihan of it all
for those who don't know he was dating
bridget moynihan i don't know how anyone
cannot but i didn't know that this is
how it happened okay
he was dating bridget moynihan they
broke up he started dating giselle and
then bridget found out she was pregnant
so they weren't even together
when she found out um but of course they
decided to like co-parent and everything
i'm sorry there's like literally like a
hair in my mouth
that stinks it's sick
sick [ __ ] sick whatever so i was now
so i feel like whenever i watch
like them interacts like i always look
at the oldest son like to see like you
know
and giselle is just like from i don't
know if she was like acting but like it
just really felt like she was like
like treating them all like they were
her own like it was just like a lovely
blended family i think they have a
lovely blended family
i think it worked out very well and
bridget moynihan when they won the the
conference
finals and now the super bowl she's
always supporting tom on social media
because that's like her
kid's father so it's just like it's
really like a picture of
you know blended family and maturity at
its finest
it's a modern family it's very it's very
nice to see and the fact that they're
all famous like makes it so much more
interesting
famous and fabulous because there are
plenty of excellent blended families
across the country but like i really
care about
giselles you know i care about the other
ones too and also i care about drew
barrymore and adam sandler's in the
movie blended because it's a fantastic
movie about blending families
i never saw it oh my god claudia is so
good like you wouldn't think it would be
good like you'd think it'd be annoying
but there's just so many great moments
it's like it's on point no i know it's
just like one of those movies i never
wanted to say and
you should treat yourself especially
since you've now voiced an interest in
abundant families
well i am going to treat myself i meant
to do it this weekend but i just like
didn't get to it but i've been meaning
to treat myself to like a glass
of wine and rv i haven't done it yet but
that's like that is a night
coming up for me at some point i know
it's in my future wow that sounds
really really nice speaking of movies i
want to say two things
okay the first is that since it's monday
and it is february we are going to
announce
our second toast movie of the week for
black history month this time we've
decided to shift
from you know black trauma to more of a
comedy
yeah this one's called little it's on
hbo max
starring issa rae regina hall and i
don't know anything about it but i've
heard it's great i've
read i know like the basic premise and
it gives me major camper vibes i'm
excited it has bce
big camper energy yes the second thing i
wanted to say as it pertains to movies
is that i
went on a journey this weekend okay and
that journey was
the lifetime movie and documentary of
wendy williams
i made the mistake i would say of
watching the movie first
and i want to preface that i've never i
know lifetime does these movies they do
the royals they do britney like everyone
gets one it's like a rite of passage
i've never seen one but i know that
they're not like good movies i know it's
very much like the hallmark genre of
movies don't bring hallmark into this
let me just say because it's like it's
like bad movies that are good don't
bring home
that's what i thought that's what i
thought hallmark would never
and i watched the scripted movie first
and i couldn't believe what i was
watching like it was so
community theater like skit like first
of all they covered
30 years of her career in a 50-minute
movie like it was so
crazy fast i just felt like it was
i i couldn't i couldn't believe how bad
it was like what i was
and it was like obviously like bad like
in a good way but like it was just
it and i'm so glad i ended up watching
the documentary because
wendy williams is a story worth sharing
like
what she has been through and you know
she doesn't get enough respect put on
her name
at all like what she did in in radio
they really say she's like the female
howard stern and she was
and like she was getting into fights
with people she like invented like
talking openly about like blind gossip
and like
you know not just what you're reading in
people magazine but like
[ __ ] that we do here like she really
invented that on the radio
and she deserves so much credit and then
with her husband kevin who was living
with uh another woman for 10 years
nine minutes away in a house that
wendy's money bought you know like the
story is so crazy and wendy goes like
all out on the documentary like she is
personal she's talking about
the fainting it was so good and i had
so much respect for wendy after the
documentary that i actually feel like
them putting that movie together
is so like it's disgraceful to her story
because it made it into a joke like it
was literally like
it was awful i mean but that's what they
do like that's what those movies are
i had never seen them yeah you went in
with a false set of expectations
um that's what it is it was so bizarre
and like i'm glad that you liked the
documentary and they got so much out of
it and i'm
like my respect for wendy williams
through the roof through the [ __ ]
roof like
no one worked harder to get where she is
and it makes sense why she's been on the
air for so long and how people just like
really like
love her like the whole thing everything
i know about her like now started to
make sense
and all the messiness it was actually
really interesting because i feel like
for a while we were reporting on here
like consecutively about
her marriage about her living in a
halfway house and the story that like
her side of the story is actually crazy
she was like i was not an addict like
kevin made me like do all these things
he was her manager he was a producer on
the show
and he was just the one like moving you
know making all these moves
so that like it would be like a good
explanation for what was going on like
it was
so when she was in the halfway house she
wasn't no addict she was living in a
halfway house though but she said she
was not an addict
but i thought at that point kevin had
already like they had already separated
i don't think so i think it was like
right after that okay
and then he stopped like being a
producer on the show and like stopped
controlling everything and now she's
like living her best
life she moved into manhattan like she's
eating caviar
with doritos like it was everything
she's just it was a real
oh and she every she's the type of
person who like she'd be talking about
like quantum physics and it's just funny
like she's hysterical
and it was really really good oh that's
so exciting i highly recommend it and
not
the movie the documentary okay don't get
confused i'm gonna add it to my content
plate
i highly recommend that sounds great
also before we get into everything i
went skiing on saturday
and i just want to say i had the most
amazing ski day i think like of
my life it was so beautiful
sunny looking blue skies snow on the
trees it was it was cold too but it was
just like
an amazing skiing day and like
especially you know they say east coast
trails aren't as great as
west coast and we see who the [ __ ] says
no that's like it that's what people say
and then that's like fact those people
sound so pretentious
mountain is a mountain no no but like
skiing in utah or like
wyoming is far superior to skiing like
upstate
or on the east coast i don't know the
mountains are just the mountain ranges
are bigger and wider there's more trails
there's more variety that's what they
say sounds zombie
it's sure but like it's just i think
it's like i think it's geographical fact
i don't know and it was just amazing my
friends and i we were all skiing like at
the same level and i skied like the best
i've ever skied
and it was just the last time i skied
with my friends at this mountain like
was the first time i ever skied and it
was a disaster like
i had never skied before and i never
thought i would ski again and so like to
come back so strong
and just like the same person on the
same mountain but like a completely
different girl
it was really like it was wonderful so i
just
i had a very fulfilling weekend so did i
but in different ways because like i
just ate everything whereas
oh i did that too oh my god literally i
had to pull my pony so tight today is to
pull my
face back to the size you guys saw it on
friday well the problem was that like me
and margo were there and
um brian's friend john was there who's
an amazing cook so it's like
you want a snack okay john will whip up
a roast chicken like he's just and he
makes it
like real hearty meals so it's like i
was eating for snacks like
chili peso like i wasn't eating like
cookies i was literally having like
full-blown meals
handmade pizza a penny on the vodka like
it was just
it was like having a chef it was amazing
that sounds really amazing well at least
you ain't good like the worst is when
you eat so much and it's all crap
yeah so um that's all you can ask for
i'm really excited to talk about the
super bowl like i have many a thought
okay so you want to get right into it
i mean i'm all caught up are you i i
think so i mean you know something might
slip out
later on you can't really you can't
really you never know but also if you're
watching on youtube like we're
definitely so blown out right now
because the sun is crazy
we're recording a little bit later than
usual but i think it's getting hot in
here
it's getting hot in here so much sun
um so let's just get into the fast life
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and jackie i asked you this once and i'm
gonna ask you again
okay what is black and white
and red all over claude
you're killing me you don't know i don't
want to get it wrong
it's the zebra insurance can be
complicated and that's why the zebra was
created
when you use the zebra.com insurance
finally feels like it's in black and
white
no more confusion just honest rates from
real companies
the zebra is the nation's leading
insurance comparison site for car and
home insurance
they can help you save money today it's
so easy go to the zebra.com and answer a
few questions to compare accurate
insurance quotes for free
and don't worry the zebra protects your
personal information and make sure there
are no hidden fees
or surprises along the way the best part
is that you can secure your insurance
from the zebra.com
or over the phone from one of their
licensed insurance agents
how much money can you save on car or
home insurance visit the zebra.com
toast that's t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash toast for insurance in
black and white
we'd love to see it okay first story the
weekend
rocks the super bowl halftime
performance maze moment becomes a
viral meme yes what did you think the
weeknd took his talents
to the super bowl last night for the
halftime show and performed a medley of
his greatest hits
you know i have many thoughts
and i don't know if people are going to
like them let's just start
let me just let's hear him i was very
excited for the weekend like i think
he's
the perfect type it was a good choice
like he has tons of hits
he's an unbelievable singer which is
like really hard to find these days like
people who
don't sound so different from like their
itunes version versus their live
versions
and i had heard that he had put seven
million of his own dollars into
production like he needed more money so
he just put his own money so i'm like
we're getting a show we're getting
lights camera action dancers we're
getting
everything of the sort we got dancers
yeah i was just like
underwhelmed by the whole thing first
and foremost
his like audio was off like the music
was so loud i couldn't hear his voice
that well and that was really bothering
me
yeah that's annoying can't imagine how
he feels about like that must be the
most frustrating thing yeah and like
that happens a lot of the times at like
award shows whatever
that can't happen at the super bowl
that's the first thing the second thing
was like i really just felt like he just
like
stood there and when i think of like
some of my favorite performances of
years past
beyonce bruno mars katy perry lady gaga
like
these predominantly women like are doing
the most dancing
act uh costume change like song song
belt belts like just doing the most
and just the weekend they just stood
there like with all these dancers who
were like
i don't know why he had so many dancers
when they were just like standing there
in their face things like
i don't know i was just like so
underwhelmed by the whole
performance yeah i like the song choices
i think like
the whole um repertoire was just like
really fun great music
but firstly i didn't like that it was in
the stands
i love when it's on the field it's like
it's so cool that like they play
football here and we're singing
it's the best part it's the best part
and so the fact that it was in the
stands just like made it even like
more of this like weird super bowl like
yeah we're not even getting a
whole house like we're getting this
section of the stands we're not even
getting this
the field then when he came down to the
field and all the dancers came down i
was like this is gonna be the craziest
moment
and they played binding blinding lights
which is the best song like
ever and it was so lackluster and then
afterwards
and do the toothbrush they should have
done the tick tock dance i don't know if
that was a consideration but they have
all of these people they have this viral
dance you know everyone at home is doing
it
because it's like a family dance family
with their parents because it's like
easy and so it would have been just so
cool and so like 20 21
meta if everyone on tv and at home was
doing the tick tock dance yeah and i
thought that was such a missed
opportunity couldn't agree more
and now it's like when i think back to
last year like do you remember how
jlo and shakira were doing the most like
belly dancing on the pole like all these
different types of
dance movements and things like there
was just like
so much work and i just saw him stand
there yeah and like he was like you know
walking here walking
and i almost threw up in the fun house
of mirrors and lights like
it was just it was so
sorry like not great it wasn't great it
was a decent
tv performance for a game that's not the
super bowl
agreed completely i wish they utilized
more of the field i didn't know that i
would feel so strongly about
field utilization yeah and then they
just had this like big
thing of like there was an orchestra and
like also some of them were dancers
and he just got lost in the sea of
randomness
and i i i was kind of let down yeah
i agree but always entertaining and we
appreciate a performance
okay so should we put in our predictions
for next year because i think like we're
we're rounding the corner to when it's
taylor swift's time you do
well i think i feel like drake could do
it that's so funny i was having that
conversation with someone
literally well because he was in a
commercial last night which was like an
amazing
drake from state farm and drake from
state farm and then it got me thinking
that like he
should be doing the super bowl at some
point well i was talking i forgot
i was having a conversation i'm like you
know i think he's more famous than the
weekend but the weeknd has more like
radio hits that more of america would
know i don't know about that
really for like longer i know but like
every single one of the weekend song
becomes like a number one ryan seacrest
top 40 like thing
so does drake though not really but but
really like um
hotline bling kiki do you love me
yeah you know um god's plan
god's there's so many like it's insane
and when when that
staircase opened up and he went into the
fun house of lights i did think someone
was going to come out i'm like oh my god
please like
scissor come save this like someone like
he actually really could have you
and i usually don't like when people
bring other people out i think he could
have used some support
yeah i'm like beyonce save us like
something
yeah but he said he wasn't gonna so i
really wasn't waiting for i know but the
stairs open so i'm like
oh and sweetie like posted something on
her instagram like
two days ago that made it seem like she
was hinting she was gonna be at the
super bowl
so i'm like oh my god sweetie is coming
but it wasn't
um so who do you think it could be next
year i just feel like
i feel like it could be ari i think it's
taylor swift's time i think enough time
has passed i know that she was
in a lengthy um contract with
diet coke for a while that i would say
ended about five years ago and i think
those contracts also have non-competes
for a certain amount of time afterward
and because it's the pepsi halftime show
for a while that's not been something
she's been able to do but i think she's
so far beyond that
um contract now i think we might i think
it might be her time and
sorry she would be perfect no one puts
together like a performance with
music fire dancers like a spectacle
better than taylor swift
she would be great i'm gonna put in my
prediction pink
please please i love pink i think she
would be sensational and i think that
she would
be excited to do it i think like i just
feel like taylor swift is not going to
do it for whatever reason whether it's
them or her it's just not going to work
out i feel like pink they can make it
work
i feel that you know yeah so well the
thing is is like taylor does not perform
music from like her first six albums and
those are the songs we would need you
know
she doesn't because they're purchased by
scooter braun
hmm so like since that whole thing has
happened
i don't think she's really performed or
released like um
like her city of lover she doesn't do
anything before lover
interesting but since they don't get
paid to do the super bowl like they
can't really be paying for the rights
doesn't like nobody get paid
no i think the the licensing like the
songs get paid
really yeah could be a good workaround
yeah but i think it's like illegal to
play music on tv without like
paying the publishing rights and stuff
okay well then maybe not
those are my thoughts okay well other
big news around the super bowl
commercials oh and the other two
performances oh yes i missed all the
beginning performances because i lost
track of time making my spinach
artichoke dip and i didn't know that it
was even 6 30 until you said
that you love that the national anthem
and i was like [ __ ] [ __ ] and then there
was a roku and i had to find the channel
so i missed it all
yeah okay let me tell you what happened
sizza slayed us like just
murdered us with her electric guitar and
her oh my god sorry her
slayed us with her electric guitar and
her delicious voice
it was is it god bless america or
america the beautiful i can never
remember
i think it's god bless america it was
stunning like
her vo her voice was
so beautiful and i loved it and i
usually don't like when they play
an instrument at the same time because
like you know just focus on one yeah but
she killed both like it was really a
beautiful rendition and i was very
excited about it and it was america the
beautiful
american beautiful sorry and then i knew
jasmine sullivan was singing the
national anthem because i saw her on
watch robin's live
i didn't know it was a duet and then i'm
like eric church and i thought it was
going to be weird i'm not going to lie
it was stunning like i have to watch it
it was a different rendition which
i think honestly the star-spangled
banner is probably one of my favorite
songs
you could say one of and i don't like
when they stray from the original that's
why whitney's was so good because it was
like
the original on steroids like she took
it to another planet
so they did this like weird little
electric guitar thing but it totally
worked
and their voices you never would have
thought like men blended perfectly like
she's very soulful she has this
delicious voice like belty voice
and he's like you know raspy country it
blended
beautifully and i don't know if like the
world loved it but i
loved it i was like getting chills i
always get the chills when like they
show you know the troops and then the
planes and they were in kuwait like
i always like start crying but it was
really good i think that's
i think i cried because it was really
good also oh wow okay great were those
all the performances that you saw yes
there were two in the beginning and then
the super bowl
sweet i mean i i have to show i'm gonna
have to catch up with them i was so
annoyed because that's always my
favorite part
no i literally would not let anyone get
up to do anything i'm like i put the tv
on at six because i know that it happens
before 6 30. completely lost track of
time like i didn't even know i was in
the realm of super bowl
time like i just it crept up on you i
played myself
congratulations okay now for the
commercials here are the top 10
commercials according to people and i
think we have
similar tastes people magazine or people
magazine
as a generalization of people people
magazine okay first one amazon alexa
michael b jordan
okay that wasn't my favorite my favorite
was rocket mortgage with tracy morgan
because like you put tracy morgan in
anything
and it's stellar but the alexa one was
really good too the alexa one was really
good and a great
like it was funny and it was also like
germaine to the product which i feel
like there were so many commercials
where it's like okay we have this
message and we have this product and
they just never
met in the middle let's talk about bruce
springsteen's three-hour
commercial with jeep where you didn't
even see a car and yeah and it's like
what is this a commercial for
any church talking and talking there's a
church in kansas i'm like this is a
tourism commercial for kansas like yeah
it was so boring that was probably the
worst commercial so if i wasn't sitting
with my friends who knew who he was i
would have never known that was bruce
springsteen oh i would have he looked
really old though
i did not i would never would have known
the crazy thing was like they pro
he's probably of all the people that
were on um commercials probably one of
the most expensive and it was the worst
commercial yeah congratulations
jeep you played yourself
okay next commercial which was so cute
was the cheetos
with mila kunis ashton kocher i have i
had a major problem with it
why the singing ashton kutcher like
it was like dubbed over and it was like
i saw her in the shower it was like
so broken like the the song was being
sung
so poorly like i had a major like
musically as someone with perfect pitch
like i had
such a problem with with the discography
of the particular
okay commercial shaggy came in and sort
of like saved the
the concept was really cute yeah the
concept was cute but i also didn't like
the way that it was filmed it was like a
little too
um hd for me and then like just it was
gross
it crumbs by the mouth like it was hard
i don't know i love the concept though
and and i think that this like
these three people were great choices
like yeah to be in your commercial
do you think that and i felt this way
that probably more than ever
each commercial had more celebrities per
capita than the others because like well
they were just celebrities haven't
worked all year and like they're ready
for like an easy
super bowl paycheck that's so
interesting they were the ones with the
streaming services where they like put
all of their celebrities
um so in those it felt like every
celebrity was there but on the other
hand i think it
it's a weird year to be incorporating so
much celebrity
into your advertisements because they're
less relevant than ever and i think that
i actually felt like there should be
less i didn't feel like there was more
but i
also felt like there should be less i
felt like there was
very few commercials that only had one
celebrity it was literally the doritos
matthew mcconaughey one and the jeep one
the jeep
long ass short film with bruce
springsteen i feel like so many
celebrities this year we're like down to
do it because
think about it like we were closed down
for so long that they haven't worked and
one commercial is literally millions of
dollars
yeah okay next commercial was bud light
seltzer lemonade
um which one was this they were like
under table this wedding party
i think i the lemon oh stupid sky
i missed i missed the whole point out so
i thought we reported that those beer
brands like weren't doing commercials
because they were gonna focus on the
vaccine
i didn't see like one emphasis on the
vaccine and every commercial i'm like is
this a vaccine
wait where's the short film about kovid
i i must have missed it
oh the commercial that i loved which is
the next one was the squarespace
five to nine yes
and it's all about your passion projects
and your side hustle and dolly was like
on the magazine cover
being so cute all about what you do like
with the time that you're not working
and and you can be using squarespace to
really like work on your dreams
i thought it was perfection i agree
like well done filmed sets everything
like original music
i want to say 10 out of 10. i agree and
so far my favorite
commercial that that we've spoken of
okay then there was ubereats wayne's
world i think i was getting a snack
yeah um don't care then there was
cadillac
edward caesar hands oh timothy chalamet
um like he can't do anything right but
he can drive a cadillac
hands-free i didn't really like i liked
seeing
him as edward scissorhands and if there
is ever like a reboot
it obviously has to be played by him but
i i didn't see the line like the thread
like how does that
have to do with the cadillac so the
thread is that they were promoting the
hands-free feature
on their new cadillac so even if you
have scissor hands
yeah you couldn't mess that and winona
was in it too and she plays that role in
the actual movie she was like reprising
her roles
yeah i know so that's pretty do you ever
see edward scissorhands i think so
you just sounded like someone who's
never i just read it and i was like oh
okay it's such a good movie i think i've
seen it but
i just i think something's a little
scary it's like yeah it's just a little
spooky
um it wasn't my favorite it was like
artfully done
and i think it was a good commercial
agreed rocket mortgage tracy morgan
winner
number of commercials same concept
different spins perfection
which i love because you know what's
become my favorite little trendy like
commercial that's not even a super bowl
but those progressive commercials with
the guy who stops you from becoming your
parents
and he's like he just says like the if
you ever actually watch it they're
really like
mini short films like they're so funny
and he's like
guys the waiter doesn't need to know
your name he doesn't care
it's just like really funny i really
like those commercials they should have
done like uh
a big big spectacular yeah but clearly
they've already made an impression
they're killing it like that guy is
hysterical and when it comes to rock and
mortar
mortgage certain is better it is you're
right
right like pretty sure it's not enough
no it's not okay next one i actually
thought this was a great commercial
t-mobile with adam levine gwen stefani
and blake shelton
hysterical the connection's messed up
and she gets the opposite of what she
asked for for her
someone uncultured it was so funny
from another country
um general motors with will ferrell i
think people were talking loudly i
missed the point
okay i saw aquafina was in it too he's
like meet me in norway
made literally no sense but had lots of
celebrities there were other people in
it too
yeah whose names i can keenan thompson
was in it also oh yeah and by the way
you know keenan's getting his own sitcom
on it yes i do i've seen commercials
where are the ad dollars like how was
like first of all i only found out about
it because when i was watching snl
why are they not promoting it because
that's going to be really good yeah
where is it where's the budget i
actually had been
seeing commercials for it i don't think
that's true okay and then 10th was
toyota's spot featuring american
paralympic swimmer jessica long one that
you didn't mention is also the mountain
dew one with john cena and it's like if
you correct the
guess if you guess the correct amount of
mountain dews that fall out of the trunk
right now and tweet it at us you'll win
a million dollars the first person and
did someone win
i i didn't follow up but i thought it
was a cute concept i missed that but
that is a cute contest there was another
celebrity in the car with him but i
don't remember her there's
just so many celebrities last night and
oh you know which commercial i liked um
amy schumer for helmand yes funny yeah
funny i wasn't expecting to see her
either but she hasn't worked
every once they got to pay their bills
yes and again an honorable mention to
the state farm
drake from state farm very cute i don't
know why people didn't feel the need to
include it but yeah
because they also had paul rudd it was
very funny yeah it was star-studded
so any other commercials you want to
mention it's hard to remember them all
it is
um the also one they didn't mention was
matthew mcconaughey and doritos 3d
how he feels flat i like cardboard and
then when he eats the 3d he like comes
to life
i just have to say like justice for him
because when they had him walking around
as like a cardboard figure he looked so
ugly like
he just he's such a handsome man and
they like made him ugly
yeah i missed it but then when he came
back to life he became 3d it was like
sexy again
but i just felt like for 75 of the
commercial he just wasn't looking his
best
damn that sucks like you it's the
biggest night of the year yeah
you know matthew mcconaughey does quite
a few commercials like he does
i mean he clearly like tests well with
um america
audiences you're right um also did you
notice that robin hood had a commercial
disgraceful disgraceful what they what'd
they say i didn't see it
like they just um had a commercial as if
like you know we're all investors
oh i'm sorry there's one commercial i
wanted to mention please do
okay oatley okay where they had their
own ceo
sitting in a field singing a song yes
okay not gonna lie like if i had a
successful company
i would probably do the same thing but
that doesn't make it a good idea like
this guy obviously just has like a team
of people around him who just like say
yes like you're doing great rob or
whatever his name is
and that's tony tony that was so
bad like and that was that was the worst
one okay
like we were all like laughing at him
you know like and i'm sure that's not
what he thought was gonna happen he
thought
you know people would turn on the tv see
his commercial be like wow i should try
oatley this guy's handsome
and instead i was like i'm never [ __ ]
drinking oatly this guy's a dope
or maybe they were like we're doing a
super bowl commercial we probably can't
be the best
but maybe we could be the worst and
therefore memorable
and memorable and they're going to talk
about it on the morning toast yeah
now oatley like how are ya and it's like
milk free milk like what is it honestly
like that sounds good because we were
saying milk is a little weird
yeah like it's like cow titty juice like
that's
exactly what it is yeah so but sorry to
be harsh with that ceo but
you're gonna put yourself out there it's
really was not it like yeah
i think he's grateful for the press yeah
no i mean you're right like there is a
method to
atrocious commercials yeah there's
something there there's something there
there was also one commercial where it
was like an office space
and they were like he whipped out his
opinion oh yeah it was like um what was
it for
it was for you whipped it out last week
at happy hour
i honestly thought it was very
inappropriate yes it's getting backlash
as it
is the one commercial uh with backlash
because first of all there's kids around
second of all don't make
light of workplace harassment that's
exactly what what's going on i was
watching and i'm like am i
is this real what company was it um
i would have to do a little bit more
research it was bad yeah
that i did see that as well b-a-d
i'm sorry that you had to it was watch
that i mean i was fine i was just like
the ad council is gonna get an earful
okay so that's our super bowl recap is
there any other moments highlights you
wanted to discuss
anything you want to say to jackson
mahones obviously you had a heart night
yeah no it was
it was obviously like hard for everyone
but especially jackson mahomes
and i just want him to know i'm thinking
about him he changed his tick tock bio
i'm the kid who gets bullied still here
and i just have so much respect for him
like
love him you have any more respect for
him after last night yeah no it's not
easy because you know all the kids on
tick tock like wanted them to lose so
like
it's because it's not even the same
reason you wanted him to win yeah and
like i just
i hope he's having a good day okay i'm
thinking of him it's so sweet of you
okay next story a little sports adjacent
relationship news that just really
took the sports adjacent relationship
world by storm is it the sports adjacent
relationship news that just took the
sports relationship adjacent
news story world by storm that's brought
to you by framebridge
yes crazy frame bridge makes it easier
and more affordable than ever to frame
your favorite things without ever
leaving the house
music's my ears add a gallery wall to
your home office or send the perfect
gift
from art prints and diplomas to photos
sitting on your phone you can frame
bridge just about anything
here's how it works go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo or
they'll send you packaging if you want
to mail in a physical piece
you preview your item in dozens of
frames styles and gallery wall layouts
you choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang
instead of hundreds you'd pay at a
framing store their prices start at 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners will get 15
off their first order at framebridge.com
when they use our code
toast like the framing industry is so
old school and frame bridge just
revitalized the whole thing
because first of all it just really
shouldn't be that hard to frame stuff
like it's
so expensive and like it's just so
unnecessary and so over complicated like
frame bridge really simplifies it
it's perfect if you're moving into a new
place or you're in a dorm room and you
just want like cute pictures of you and
your friends the fact that you can
upload straight from your phone
is fabulous it's really easy to use and
it's so reasonably priced you can get
pictures of you and your friends framed
or you can just get pictures of yourself
and
framed and put it in your bedroom and
that's what jackie that's what i do
and it's honestly iconic get started
today frame your photos or send someone
the perfect gift
go to framebridge.com and use promo code
toast to save an additional 15 off your
first order
that's framebridge.com promo code toast
framebridge.com promo code toast it's
everything of the sort
everything of the sort now for the big
sports adjacent relationship news aaron
rodgers says that he's engaged
days after shailene woodley dating
rumors
so aaron rodgers got the most valuable
player award during saturday night's nfl
honors congratulations to aaron and the
whole rogers family
that doesn't seem weird because like if
you were the most valuable player like
you should be at the super bowl i think
it's like
and like all of these awards like minus
the people who are playing because they
can't come to the
to the right that's fair um and then
like the super bowl has an mvp also
right right which one too i wonder who
was last night's mvp
my boyfriend i don't know if you have
you met him yet tom really he didn't
really stand out
i call him it's really so crazy that he
won we haven't even discussed like
the sporting aspect of the fact that the
bucks won like tom brady can just go to
any team and just win a super bowl like
he
is the greatest of all time yeah and i
thought for sure like that
he was just like trying to prove a point
like winning one last super bowl and
like he was gonna retire now but it like
he said when he won like i'm not going
anywhere why would he retire he
literally just proved that he
is the best player in the game period at
any age like
because that's like for for sports like
you go out on you go out on
top but like when you're st but he
doesn't feel like he's
i would it's done if i were a top
athlete i wouldn't go out when i'm like
clearly in my prime i would go out when
i'm like number two or three
yeah still at the top but not like i'm a
waste just to sit at home yeah the thing
is is that like they're more inclined to
go out on top because like
if tom brady leaves now great like he
left after just like
this miraculous super bowl whereas if he
goes next year and he loses like you go
out on a loss like it's not a risk you
want to take especially when money isn't
even really a factor like
yeah but or he could win again like you
know of course but then it's a gamble
like at this point it's like no i won i
did it i could bounce i think he's a
gambling man
i guess i'm not but you are you would
keep going right
yeah of course i mean especially if you
were in pennsylvania i have very bad
judgment when it comes to gambling i
don't know if i'm the person to ask
okay so aaron rodgers won the nf nfl nba
mvp and he revealed that he's engaged
just days after reports surfaced as he's
dating shailene woodley
he said quote it's an honor to win this
award for the third time 2020 was
definitely a crazy year
filled with lots of change growth some
amazing memorable moments
180 straight days of having my nose
hairs scraped playing for
very little fans or no stands the entire
season i got engaged and i played some
of the best football of my career
so he thanked he then thanked his
fiancee without naming names but he said
he also got engaged that's two
conversations
two confirmations that he's an engaged
man days before
the woman of the apple of his eye is
shailene woodley
i think it's safe to say he's engaged to
shailene yeah no and i know they like
just announced it but we were talking
about in july so they've been together
for
close to a year i would think and the
fact that we know so little about it
like makes me feel like this could be it
i know like and also when you do get
engaged quickly but not
too quickly i just feel like it bodes
well and also even the fact that i would
never pair these two people together
makes me think like maybe it's love
no maybe like we're not seeing something
but there's something the only way that
these two people like get engaged is if
they're
in love well yeah hopefully no but like
sometimes you get you
or you date someone for the idea of them
yeah yeah yeah big
but these two have nothing in common
right so they must just genuinely
love each other well one one can hope
you know yeah i think that's great aaron
rodgers has had quite like you know a
journey in his
personal life and we're happy for him
but he clearly just like wants to love
you know he's
he's constantly in a relationship like
term trying to make it work i'm assuming
and i think he's
he just wants a committed relationship
and i hope that's what he's found here
personally i'm still not um building a
ship but i think i'm gonna take her out
on someone else's little crew
yeah no definitely like a tour a tour
i'm not ready to make a full commitment
because i've never even seen a picture
of the two of them you know
yes i agree and i still see it as an odd
pairing i'm not gonna lie
i agree but nonetheless happy for them
know that i am even if i
can't understand that's literally it i
can't understand no and i refuse to but
i'm happy for them but i'm trying
i'm trying okay next story more
relationship news the rest
of the show is relationship news i guess
like super bowl and it's february brings
out like the love
oh yeah it's cuffing season it's cuffing
season but jlo and a-rod hit the super
bowl 2021 amid
malice madison lacroix drama so you're
just pretending like this [ __ ] doesn't
exist right i want to talk about this
like this strategy
of them just ignoring the fact that like
another celebrity is saying that
she had conversations with your man okay
celebrity is a strong word because yes
she's very famous but i think in jlo's
eyes she's like an
influencer reality star like i don't
think jayla wants to
in in her opinion i mean i don't know
jlo personally but it seems like
this would be like for her to
acknowledge it like a step down jayla's
the biggest star in the world and this
is like a small reality show 100 percent
but it's like it's out there and
everyone's talking away it's on tv i
think jlo even watches bravo sometimes
like
for sure it's not something that's just
going away yeah and but they're acting
like it is they put up a united front in
super bowl 2021 their first public
appearance since the rumors swirled
um in a video posted to a rod's
instagram account on sunday he and jayla
were seen walking side by side after
exiting
a private jet so if we were waiting for
any sort of
breakup or statement or you know
statement saying that they are you know
working on their relationship committed
to each other blah blah blah it's not
happening
i don't know i just feel like the fact
that he got caught with madison lacroix
is definitely not
you know a one-time thing i'm sure that
there have been many incidents if he's
this messy like
right and there were so many i mean
obviously unverified accounts
yeah and a lot of these accounts that
we're sharing that madison was talking
about a-rod we're also sharing
other women talking sharing their
stories so like maybe she knows and like
this is just a part of their arrangement
because i don't know why you would let a
man embarrass you like that if you
didn't
if you weren't okay with it yeah but i
definitely am just like looking at
them questionably no i mean we literally
said last week how i thought they were
the best couple to ever exist in the
entire history
of hollywood and now i'm like i feel
embarrassed for
for them like this is so like tacky this
whole thing
like facetiming younger girls like why i
loved them so much they were like such
an age-appropriate couple and they were
just like
doing the most for everyone and
everything and like
they were so supportive of each other's
businesses like and now i'm just like
you're embarrassing us a-rod like get it
together get it together
well the final story no shade to madison
lacroix i'm just saying like
in terms of their relationship yeah
because medicine look right it's
beautiful like a vase rod i probably
call her too
face time face time um through the final
story a little more relationship news is
it the bible story a little bit more
relationship news that's brought to you
by manscape you know what it's actually
not
oh excuse something
do you want it it's not it could be i
couldn't no you told me i have been
opening no you told me this is your ship
sir us it's brought to you by manscaped
it is i was just teasing you guys
um if you're looking for a valentine's
day present you gotta get manscaped
all the way give the best present about
this holiday season the company that
offers precision engineer tools
for your man's family jewels honestly
that's an amazing valentine's day
present because i just got it for zach
for just you know
being him yeah and he absolutely loved
it and i think that's such a perfect
valentine's day gift because one it's
useful
but it also like sets the mood a little
bit yeah no manscaped is just a great
brand because i think like
a lot of times at least ben like he's
weird about stuff you know
the manscape is like yeah you know we're
gonna escape yeah we're men
it's just branded really well and the
products are excellent and ben has been
using the razor a lot
and it's like a thoughtful gift and it's
also like a little kinky
a little so the one that we got from
manscape is their new
performance package and we really uh i
my house we love it all the products are
so cute so like on bedside they look all
like
you know sleek and sexy and they have
great products
they have great um razors that's like
their their best product that ben is
obsessed with
the manscape performance package is the
ultimate men's hygiene bundle so
if your man struggles with hygiene and
you're just looking for like a a subtle
way
to tell them you love them this
valentine's day head over to manscaped
their package comes with all the tools
to clean up his delicate places
included in this new package is the weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
which is waterproof and uses 9000 rpm
motor powered 360
degree rotary dual blade system so it'll
cut the [ __ ] out of those nose hairs
the nose and ear hair trimmer provides
proprietary skin safe technology
which helps prevent nick's snags tugs
and all those delicate holes
so 79 of partners polled admitted that
long nose hair is a major turn off
so why not use the best tools out there
and you can get 20 off
plus free shipping with the code morning
manscaped.com
all of their products they have a crop
preserver a crop reviver they've got a
lawn mower
they're all named really fun but they
all work really really well 20
off anything on the website
manscaped.com but in order to get that
20
off you got to use the code morning
ladies this is the perfect gift for you
and your man
trust me he will thank you and men make
this the number one thing on your wish
list
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code morning manscaped.com
your man snowballs will thank you lol
okay sorry fifth and final story fifth
and final story
you're not gonna like this peter webber
and kelly flanagan
are working on their relationship as
they reunite at a super bowl event
peter and kelly made fans go wild after
they were spotted at the same pre-super
bowl
lv parties over the weekend i personally
prefer
super bowl gucci but it's just me
i'm much more of a super bowl product
i'm a super bowl fendi really but super
bowl lv was
very very sweet honestly very um
they were both at the same party and a
source tells e news that they were
together the entire night as a source
put it
they looked happy and were having fun
drinking and dancing together and with
their friends
so it like i'm happy for them i just
don't ship these to it ever i've said
this once i say it again like queens do
not belong with sorry people i agree but
you know what
i hate peter i saw this news when you
said queens don't agree
don't relationship with sorry people i
was like yes yes
but when i saw that they like working on
the relationship and like we're seeing
together i was
honestly happy i really like them i like
them
no i'm happy for peter that like he has
one good thing going for him which is
like taste because kelly's a [ __ ]
queen
but i'm like still mad at all the time
peter raised it during his season like
he was honestly
in recent memory the worst bachelor of
our time
i don't know the indecisiveness and then
matt and hannah and then ended up with
kelly like
no but it was like that sounds like a
journey and that sounds interesting you
always remember things more fondly than
when you actually experienced them and
now i'm like peter
oh i haven't had that even though i'm
the queen of like hating things when i'm
in it and then like
years later i'm like that was great yeah
but no with peter he's aged very poorly
in my mind
oh in my mind it's like him and kelly
it's just all
very redeeming and it's an
unconventional way that they it's all
kind of
strange but the fact that they were
together for so long i was like okay
this is it
and so i kind of want them to get back
together i don't know i've said it once
i've said it again
queens do not hang out with sorry people
okay well
and that's by the way that's just the
way the world works like i
that's just how it is well you know i
kind of like when we disagree on stuff
because it's like no matter what happens
one of us will be happy with the outcome
that's better than both of us being
unhappy that's so true so
we'll see we'll see um so those are the
past five speaking of the bachelor it's
on tonight
yes so we're back on our weekly recaps
bachelor
we've got this week the salt lake city
reunion start oc just ended thank god
southern charm just ended right is there
one more no it ended
fabulous i just need and jersey starts
soon so i'm really excited
very very excited and i think that's it
i think i didn't watch atlanta last
night because oh my gosh super bowl
i don't even know if it was on oh well
because of the super bowl great
and so yes we'll be back tomorrow with a
bachelor recap and just another fabulous
show
by two fabulous gals just like a crazy
week now that it started in this way
i think it's actually gonna go the rest
quickly because i feel very rushed
me too so i'm excited and i hope
everyone had a great
weekend we look forward to another
fabulous week of tmt thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitch or public radio i
have ready to cast box
all the places sorry if you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast and
leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are this has been my pleasure as a
new york times best-selling author to
greet you this morning have a great day
bye bye